[Music]
give me money news submitted by my fish
ran away like that
it's really sad cuz it's a harmonica
yeah
alright a man who left a threatening
note on a Porsche is arrested for
extortion what I do that all the time
what the [ __ ]
okay what do you do you like pass like
aggressive notes on not passive
aggressive highly aggressive if I ever
[ __ ] see your car on the street I'm
going to take your children and kill
them
wow that's mean I just have just write
it for me because I can't write nice
ones the [ __ ] white people talk about
the car that was parked in my spot and
then she was like we paid 200 bucks for
this and next time we will tell your car
so don't Park here anymore please did
you go upstairs and type it and print it
on the side or she wrote it on the thing
eating and then she put it on the what's
the thing you think that thing good
thing thing thing some kind of paper
that you don't really mean anymore Bing
Bing and then you put it on a thing of
things
like I think it was like a month or so
ago somebody left a threatening note on
an ambulance and they went to jail for
that that's like a thing now you can't
leave me notes but what I think is cool
is that they said that he was extorting
him
well what did that what did the note say
they say they're gonna kidnap the kids
again
is it Davis handwriting is elderness
yeah cuz I live six lives in Portland
Oregon and this note was left on a
Porsche SUV and it read listen up I know
where you live oh [ __ ] I will come after
you when you are sleeping
sounds like a Christmas song I'll come
back in your sleep
you better not beat up or I'll take your
Porsche away
that was too good and really just means
just demanding $10,000 and saying and
then leaving in instructions as to where
to drop it off that's exactly [ __ ]
extortion mm-hmm that's also a great
idea and they use the college-bound the
paper I mean they drew a little image
here is that leave it on the water meter
what the best part about this is the top
it says listen up I like even the
letters a stick-up I have never heard
somebody use that phrase before that's
true yeah like in real life like I
always saw it like an old Cowboys or
westerns or something you already have
their attention the fact that they're
reading your [ __ ] they can't listen
because they're reading it so that's the
race here you think it's a white guy oh
wait hold on let's think about yeah they
also and do it don't tell anyone or I
will end you
well it's easier and I'm watching think
could they put exclamation mark so how'd
they find this person yeah I think it's
a white guy Oh or I think it's a Mexican
guy we don't say listen up we don't know
no no that's one say he's smart okay
he's a Ghost Rider
all right all right let me just tell you
guys right now this is a black guy for
sure this is a black guy that probably
ran out of opiates and also it was more
like a listen up oh I didn't read it
like that yeah it could like a break
yourself yeah listen up
oh I didn't even I was like listen up
buddy what is the second paragraph C or
the neck are the lines also rhyming -
I'm a good detective oh yeah oh it's a
third-grader I know it's not Asian
because Asian would be like can you hear
me yeah it'll be on that real paper uh
hello kitty all right yeah towards the
end it says you look here for me after
that
and I will not hurt you or your family
the owner ended up going to the police
station even though the note said not to
so the police set up an undercover
mission and they put a bank bag with
fake money in the location though this
is the most childish setup I've ever
heard of my life they put a burlap sack
with a big golden dollar tied on it this
is the most I'm not gonna know do the
Hamburglar come out like what's off buzz
ha wait how much money did he want dude
that's like a bundle this big yeah it's
like this big also he's a modest guy
like it's like Porsche I only want 10
grand
can I just comment on that water cooler
though water meter look if you guys saw
that drawing I mess up he's quite the
artist because he and he did a good job
oh you know that's not easy
he didn't even sketch it out or anything
the police caught him when he showed up
to take the money oh and we have a
picture of this guy okay that's how it
is no it could be like Latin or a Cuban
or something to these nothing's browning
or something yeah there we go not ours
browning not ours what if he's mixed oh
yes a Latina mom hey ray brown you'll
name our kids Felix no
villain raid that's Imre Dylan ray
Dylan hey Bob rain the rain the rate is
like great from like Louisiana yeah
no the two first names really give it
off Dylan grave bro not Dylan one like
Bobby Bob Bobby Bob browning yeah so he
was arrested and he admitted to setting
up the whole extortion and he also
admitted the reason why he did this was
to settle a $9,000 gambling debts so
what's the extra thousand four to go
[ __ ] down he [ __ ] up you know what
have been in more scarier note is if he
had a really arbitrary number I want
four thousand five hundred sixty eight
dollars and 33 cents that would freak me
the [ __ ] out a psychopath they're like
oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] right [ __ ] like that really I
would just be like this person is very
exact I like this person's on drugs so
as for such a specific this dude isn't
more debt though because he posted his
$7,500 bond in the news release and I
can't even so he got out oh that's
interesting I don't know what he posted
his bond he's out free he's gonna watch
this video so he just put his gonna look
for us [ __ ] weapons right for you
[ __ ]
they do say though that the prosecutors
are indicating that they want to seek a
departure sentence which is a longer
prison sentence if they are able to
convict him because they're saying that
he committed the crime because he was
quote motivated entirely or in part by
the race color religion ethnicity
national origin or sexual orientation of
the victim so what they're considering
it a hate crime
wait that's like everyone though
religious yeah sexual orientation gender
race that's every person yeah what are
they what is he motivated by from now on
anytime somebody's mean to me I'm saying
it's a hate crime yeah everything falls
under that
female that's yeah but she might be like
like I don't know Hindu and then like
nowadays yeah too different yep that'll
be yeah I'm deal to are saying that the
defendant must be incarcerated to ensure
Public Safety if there's a asian guy
that I don't like I'm gonna do that hate
crime but you can't like me well you
have to just find one difference yep you
could just you could make more money
than them or something yeah
you don't like me cuz classes classes
that is the thing like he makes $5,000
more than me but he hates me she likes
Keroppi [ __ ] I like marshmallow or
whatever how did they is this like a
random portion yeah yeah yeah how did
some random ass but they but there's a
lot more expensive cars than Porsches
out there so wash SUV I mean but it's
importantly actually uh where would you
see a Porsche in Portland when I think
of Portland I think of like hipsters
feminist bookstores and craft beer I
think I think Prius and old cars yeah so
he probably saw that portion he got
really excited he was like they got
money money yep hmm cuz I see I see like
Porsche McCann's all over the place in
LA so it's like not that big of a deal
but important that you are not fazed at
all you're like why did he pick this guy
yeah well that's what I'm saying
yeah because he could have done that
same threat to a person with the Prius
it would have been the same [ __ ] well
actually now that I think about it since
everybody in Portland is riding bicycles
pretty much and walking like a Prius is
probably real rare too you know
hypothetically speaking
everybody portal is pissed off right now
I did before hipsters took it over and I
was 12 years old
and it was a nice City what's wrong with
hipsters they're like a medieval sword
because you know don't be like oh great
they came into a [ __ ] up neighborhood
and now because white people are there
police are gonna start coming by but the
other side is man you just [ __ ] up the
town homey how does that relate that has
that a medieval sort because now the
locals gotta go so it's a double-edged
sword
kids medieval you know double-edged
sword yeah yeah okay know what though
you know what they do this to poor white
people to Austin Texas
imagine seeing a Porsche in Austin Texas
they probably look crazy I'll know i
defending everybody's like dude if you
go to Wyoming and they see a Toyota
camera they're like what's up what it's
in from Virginia like I never saw a
Porsche until I moved to LA what part of
Virginia were you from like the tobacco
fields not like you know like what did
you see farms everywhere yeah yeah it
was real rural Oh like my old roommate
she came from Indiana she would talk
about how like there's just corn
everywhere I'm like I don't see growing
[ __ ] that's scary that's the [ __ ]
that's where all the scary movies happen
I was another corner I always wonder out
there like you know were they like the
forested areas I you in legit kill
somebody and nobody would know for like
a long time yeah easy
that's scary that's why this guy was
doing that stuff oh [ __ ]
[Music]